[Musique]
bonjour à tous merci de nous rejoindre
pour ce nouveau numéro de vip
aujourd'hui je reçois un auteur un
acteur metteur en scène l'humoriste dont
le compte instagram fait exploser les
compteurs si je puis dire
il s'agit de thomas poitevin son compte
les pe de thomas est il à l'extrême
délicatesse de mettre en avant les
yvelines à travers un de ses personnages
à savoir gentiane confinés dans le
village de montfort l'amaury au coeur du
bocage yvelinois comme elles le disent
si bien voilà thomas poitevin bonjour
bonjour ironique merci d'être avec tout
notre ces conditions un petit peu
compliqué le confinement merci beaucoup
voilà mais on va y arriver
voilà on la charia alors dites moi vous
êtes l'auteur d'un compte instagram donc
qui remporte un succès d'un go on ou
vous êtes couvert d'éloges dans tous les
médias on parle de finesse de pépites de
rire de drôlerie d'originalité enfin
bref pour ceux qui vous ne connaissent
pas encore il s'agit donc d'une galerie
de portraits chacun a sa perruque
d'où le nom les perruques de thomas
voilà et bah ils sont en train de vivre
chacun à leur manière tout bonnement du
mieux qu'ils peuvent leur petit
confinement alors première question
quand comment a démarré ce conte qu'est
ce qui vous a donné cette idée
magnifique c'est à dire non un peu moins
d'un an
enfin ça date d'il ya un an j'étais en
train de devenir plus hauteur que
comédien j'ai été longtemps comédiens
qui lâche commençait à devenir vraiment
auteurs professionnellement et j'avais
ce petit reste dans vie de travail et
des personnages ce que j'avais fait ça
dans un spectacle j'avais adoré ça donc
je me suis dit j'ai les les désespérés
ne manque pas de panache au mieux sa
lancée et est donc il ya un an je me
suis dit je t'ai pas leur faire de
spectacle mais j'ai envie de de
continuer cette aventure là dans un
petit espace comme ça dans mon coin
donc je m'étais dit bon un petit compte
instagram voilà
le mes copains vont me suivre et puis je
m'amuserai de temps en temps à faire ça
ce sera très bien et puis ça ça ça a été
très surprenant le succès de la berge
avaient attaqué deux copains dit morin
vous êtes très beau cul là il y en a
presque soixante deux mille ou d'accord
et combien de personnages dans cette
galerie où je pense qu'il y en a bien
presque 25 presque une petite trentaine
maintenant il ya les rues les récurrents
qui reviennent souvent récurrents
alors on peut parler de cette fameuse
bages anciens tiens si on regarde et un
petit confort l'amaury très courageuse
gentiane j + 19 lors de ma sortie
quotidienne pour récupérer des denrées
de première nécessité
je me suis soudain mise à regarder le
monde de quoi montfort l'amaury est il
le nom et soudain une épiphanie cet
homme qui me tend chaque jour le pain
aux figues sans gluten de françois-marie
que j'appelle naïvement un boulanger la
cinquantaine puissante des sources y
toujours frondeurs racontant de vieilles
blessures et une gestuelle nerveuse et
précise d'artisans qui s'est fait tout
seul à la force du sacrifice de ses
parents qu'est ce qu'il apporte ce oui
vous fait rire encore c'est ça qui est
beau on rit à chaque fois mais tant
mieux
dites-moi l'accession de la perruque
qu'est ce qu'il apporte de particulier à
part le côté éventuellement comique au
bas d'une perruque ça ça change une
morphologie pitch huit votants car oui
ça mais de ça m'aide à trouver des fois
je en fait je pars pas de personnage je
parle d'une idée je construis un
discours un sketch et souvent je trouve
le personnage en europe ce pardon en
trouvant une perruque dans mon stock de
perruque je regardais je choisis donc
oui ça change le visage
pardon et donc j'allais vous demander
qu'est ce qui déclenche la la création
d'un personnage sa mise
sa naissance si je peux dire alors très
très souvent c'est sa part de quelques
mots une petite phrase souvent une
expression cc c'est toujours la première
brique dans l'écriture c'est une
expression qui soit qui m'a fait rire
soit qui m'a troublé soit ça peut être
aussi un souvenir qui revient à l'accord
est alors dans cette es comment est-ce
que vous donc vous il y en a à peu près
25 vous m'avez dit alors comment est ce
que vous choisissez des faire revenir de
façon récurrente ou de les supprimer est
ce qu'il ya eu des morts pour pouvoir en
créer d'autres
comment vous faites j'aimerais bien
faire mourir un personnage mais c'est
dur de faire rire avec ça oui c'est vrai
c'est vrai ça choquerait beaucoup de
gens je souffrais inattendue en plus je
l'envié le désir s'est séparé fléchi il
ya quand ça colle quand un texte colle
avec un personnage je le fais sinon je
je ne me dis pas il faut absolument que
je refasse venir revenir et ça arrange
jan janssen est revenu là parce qu'on
sert confiné donc elle a repris son
journal de greffe sur mais sinon son
histoire était a priori terminée
malheureusement les revenus très bien
mais donc oui c'est ça c'est pas parce
qu'un personnage est plus laïque et
qu'un autre que vous vous dites bah
tiens cela je tiens bon filon je vais le
revel reprendre non non non je pourrais
pas écrire comme ça je n'arriverais pas
trop pure c'est qui la voix off par
exemple la copine qui répond la fille de
galles est elle tout ça c'est moi c'est
toujours moi qui vois rien ouais ça
prend quand même temps de faire une
vidéo on ça prend quelques heures une
grosse demi journée ce qui est le plus
long c'est d'écrire et puis et puis
après ça va assez vite mais je fais
quand même beaucoup de prises quand je
tourne et puis je m'auto je m'auto
dirige donc c'est quand même un sacré
truc de s'auto diriger
ouais c'est plus rare mais ça arrive
aussi je me donne je me donne des
petites tapes sur l'épaule je suis
fatigué je comprends bon et alors j'ai
envie de découvrir une autre une autre
amie parce qu en fait sont un peu tous
nos amis maintenant j'ai envie de
découvrir jocelyne qui elle va aller
bien bravo si elle fait elle fait tout
ce qu'elle peut pour aider les petits
commerçants pendant pendant le
confinement et on va la découvrir
justement pas plus tard qu'hier je veux
dire à l'ema jocelyne fais toi plaisir
je me clic incorrect le dernier eric
reinhardt ebadi thouars rech
comme à petit les braises des plantes et
de pacar tâter quoi bon vu la tronche
quel tirage même pas osé l'anglais pour
résultat je me suis forcé à lire toute
la soirée
le dernier marc levy l'arrière garde
quoique me dira ça m'a pris deux heures
et puis à ma grande surprise est là une
petite musique aurait ouais mais bon les
médecins m accroche la nature dans la
même soirée
je me demande mon petit agneau charmant
de chaque région lance comme la méthode
et bats la viande un arrière-goût de
saumon fumé notre journal une craquante
et alors qu'est ce qu'il est
l'expression qui a pu déclencher ce
personnage vous en souvenez ou pas ce
oui c'est une situation cg imaginer
quelqu'un qui se plaignait tous qui
critiquait beaucoup tout le monde autour
d'elle et qui comme tout le monde fait
faillite ou est au bout du rouleau ne se
sentait plus de se permettre de
critiquer tout le monde du coup il est
un peu frustré du coup elle mange
beaucoup chez elle
oui les boulimiques à la pauvre mais un
petit peu oui un petit peu bah oui c'est
normal
et dites-moi est-ce que vous allez
rester sur ce format où j'ai cru
entendre que vous pensiez à 8 minutes
c'est vrai ou c'est une blague
je travaille encore ça fait longtemps
que j'ai initié ça mais c'est vrai que
mes vidéos sont source
mais c'est depuis cet été je travaille
là dessus en fait j'aimerais faire une
vidéo
instagram très longue qui fasse même un
quart d'heure vingt minutes un peu comme
les lacs
bella court métrage oui presque comme un
petit court métrage parce que il m'a
souvent dit et c'est pour ça que ça
marche est aussi c'est que souvent sur
instagram c'est très rapide et les past
et d'humoriste et une minutes maximum
moi je suis très nerveux je prends mon
temps donc je me suis dis mes toiles
paris de durer encore plus longtemps
donc là j'essaie de construire toute une
histoire avec un personnage qui dure 15
minutes
toujours tout seul à seul personnage
jour tout seul ouais c'est qu'ils sur la
chaîne à je peux pas vous dire encore
quand on veut on peut
bon ce sera une femme ces femmes et
dites moi et danièle seux ce grand-père
qui illustre un peu les les nouveaux
comportements donc encore une fois du
confinement qui parle par skype avec sa
fille et ses petits enfants qui est qui
rempli d'amour mais qui ne le montrent
pas et qui qui est un petit peu méchant
voix au satis indique pardon j'ai envie
qu'on le découvre aussi et puis on en
parle après d'accord d'accord c'est pour
ça que vous n'êtes pas souvent si tous
les jours je vais depuis je rigole vous
avez vous gagné à ebi moi j'ai la mienne
avec daniel et félix va nous dire un mot
qui ça en petits enfants ils la petite
grosse je la connais mais le deuxième
jeu les vues oui papa quand on est allé
dit bonjour à ton grand père c'est un
bébé il va pas dire bonjour bonjour
comment faire lorsque vous faites le jeu
fait la voix de félix parce qu'il est
petit comment comment peut-on imaginer
un grand père aussi méchant c'est le
voir aux jeux je crois qu'il n'est pas
si méchant que ça il est il est dur il a
un peu sucré salé comme disait ma grand
mère sally les îles et ouais mais il
n'est pas il n'est pas méchant
non je pense que je me suis je les aime
beaucoup ce personnage mais je le jeu en
fait je me dis que quand je serai vieux
je ressemblerais à ça c'est quelqu'un de
gentil au fond mais qui qui qui on en a
plus rien à carrer de rien en fait
qu'ils deviennent sans filtre oui sans
fil parce que la petite grosse c'est pas
très très gentil ni pour lentilles et
puis il ya une autre vidéo il en fait
une blague un petit peu salée comme vous
dites quand cela se passe il faut le
dire la caisse et a dû carrefour la
bombe c'est toi qui s'est marié sa fille
panique en fin de carrière de rire de
toute façon on s'en fiche et dites moi
alors ce succès d iran ça vous a apporté
des propositions ça qu'est ce que ça a
changé dans votre vie tout change et ça
a permis de me faire connaître
ça me permet de refaire un spectacle je
te rassure nouveau spectacle ce sera
l'année prochaine en septembre et puis
avant je vais faire des petits extraits
d' aider et c'est en fait dans
différents endroits
et puis et puis ce qui me fait très
plaisir c'est que ça m'a permis de
travailler comme auteur et de trouver du
travail en tant que plume ce soit pour
d'autres soit pour de la fiction à la
télévision i-télé la wii je travaille
sur un projet de série télé oui mais qui
demain j'imagine non non non je veux je
pense que c'est ça va prendre du temps
mais c'est formidable c'est un jeu fait
ça avec une co scénariste avec je
m'entends très bien c'est très agréable
c'est votre amie hélène françois non
c'est mon ami mélusine reno mais vous
avez tellement d'amis c'est vrai j'avais
oublié et dites moi je suis comme malade
au rhdp de la grande époque qui ne
manquent pas mais oui suffit d'acheter
la carte
dites moi comme malheureusement le
confine on s'arrêtera est ce que vous
allez nous lâcher ou pas
non non je vais continuer à mon rythme
de toute façon j'avais lancé la chaîne
avant confinement oui et elle a prises
grâce au confinement
mais je je je vais pas m'arrêter je
pense oui m'enfin pardon je vous coupe
mais vos personnages là on les voit
vivre le confinement donc après on va
les voir vivre autrement dans la vraie
vie entre guillemets tôt oui oui
ah oui c'était déjà le cas pendant
l'entré deux oui j'ai fait une pastille
à l'extérieur j'ai moins de la
recommencer
on était alors ça se passe dans les
cévennes
ah bah non mais c'est parce que je
regarde toujours les mêmes je suis je
suis trop fan de certains et du coup
bombe alors ça c'est une bonne nouvelle
vous nous abandonnez pas heureusement
vous avez une idée de l'âge du public
qui vous suit ou pas pas trop je pense
qu'il ya je sais mais ça touche me tombe
j'ai l'impression qu'il ya plus de
femmes que d'hommes
et là je me en fait il ya une il ya une
catégorie statistique sur instagram et
je veux pas la regarder
je ne sais pas pourquoi ça m'a peut-être
que ça me fait peur mais je j'y pense
ça vous ferait peur de plaire à qui non
mais j'ai pas envie de savoir c'est
comme un peu au père noël
moi je pense que vous plaisez à tous les
âges écoutez moi j'ai un gène tic et
jeunes et i mais je lui ai montré ma dit
j'avoue c'est drôle
super le jeu est super n'est ce pas bon
ben écoute et thomas un grand merci pour
exister déjà de tout ce que vous nous
avez donné de souffrir de lumière et de
et de rire pendant ce confinement morose
je vous décerne la légion d'honneur ou
un truc comme ça ce qui vous plaira je
remercie
merci d'avoir pris du temps et puis
donnez nous des mais la nuit est désolé
pour le côté un peu bateau qui tombe à
la guerre comme à la guerre comme disait
ma grand mère merci beaucoup
bon ben ça suivra les perruques de
thomas et sinon sur ie sur facebook on
est d'accord et sur facebook
voilà à bientôt thomas merci un au
revoir
c'était super ciao merci
[Musique]
il